hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry and.com and in this video I want
to go over how to clean dentures as a
nurse so as a nurse you're gonna be
providing care to patients who wear
dentures and your role will include
helping the patient take those dentures
out cleaning the dentures and providing
mouth care because a lot of times
patients are really sick and they can't
get out of bed and do this like they
normally would at home so you'll help
them at night with doing that because
they don't sleep with the dentures at
night and you'll help them in between
the meals after they eat and some things
you want to keep in mind whenever you
are taking care of dentures is that you
don't damage them because they're very
expensive and they don't become lost
because you have a lot of people going
in and out of the patient's room the
patient's sick they're not really
keeping track of where their dentures
are so you'll as a nurse you'll want to
keep them secured so first what you want
to do is you want to gather your
supplies which will include a denture
cup which you'll want to put a patient
label on the denture cup on the lid or
write the patient's name the room number
so they don't get confused with any
other person's dentures also a soft
bristled toothbrush with cleaning pace
for the dentures it's really recommend
that you use a denture cleaning pace
instead of toothpaste because that can
be abrasive to the dentures a kidney
Basin towels paper towels and gloves and
also be sure that you ask the patient if
they brought any of their denture
cleaning supplies because some patients
may prefer that you use their supplies
then you'll want to perform hand hygiene
and dawn gloves and then assist the
patient with removing their dentures so
patients remove their dentures and we
put them in the denture cup with the lid
on it and we dr. gloves and perform hand
hygiene and now we're at the sink area
so first what I like to do is I like to
prep my sink area because I don't want
any of my supplies to become
contaminated so since we're going to be
turning the faucet on and off the lot
we're going to put some extra paper
towels there so we can just not
contaminate our gloves and we can use
the towel to turn it on and off then
we're going to lay down a towel and this
to help protect our supplies so let me
be doing that just lay it down nice and
neat and what we're going to put on it
is our toothbrush with our bristles up
our cleaning pace some extra paper
towels to dry the Basin out with our
basin of course our dentures in our
denture cup and our gloves then we're
going to prep the inside of the sink
this is really one of the most important
steps you want to take when you are
cleaning dentures and what we're going
to do is we're going to create this like
cushion in the bottom of the sink
because just in case if you draw up the
dentures and let me tell you from
cleaning a lots of dentures they become
slippery and they can easily fall out of
your hand so what we're going to do is
we're going to just lay these towels
down in the sink and then we're going to
turn on our water but first let's pull
the stopper and then just fill it up
half way with water and again this just
provides a nice cushion just in case
those dentures were to fall into the
sink
okay and it's about halfway so we're
gonna go ahead and turn the water off
now we're going to prep our toothbrush
and again you want to use like a soft
bristled toothbrush or check with your
patient or your supplies and see if you
have a denture cleaning brush which is
specifically made for cleaning dentures
and we're going to use some cleaning
paste and I know a lot of hospitals you
may only have access to regular
toothpaste you can use that but just
keep in mind that regular toothpaste can
be abrasive to the dentures if they have
whiteners in them but we're going to use
a cleaning pace and we're going to put
it on our toothbrush just like how you
normally would your own toothbrush at
home and put the cap back on the
toothpaste and set our brush down for a
second while we get everything else
prepped now we're ready to clean the
dentures so what we're gonna do is I'm
just going to rearrange the supplies
just here a little bit that up here at
our base in here and what we're gonna do
is we're going to dawn our gloves
because any time you're touching
dentures you need to always wear gloves
to protect you from getting any germs
from the dentures because the mouth is
has a lot of bacteria in it and we're
going to turn our water on warm
we don't want it hot because it can
damage the dentures and we don't want it
too cold because it really won't do the
job so we're gonna turn our water on
warm and we're gonna get our dentures
and what we want to do first is we're
going to rinse them off we're gonna put
them in the kidney Basin because we want
to clean this denture Cup so we'll have
a nice clean area for the dentures to be
returned to so grab your dentures and
hold them firmly and then just rinse
them hit him in the kidney basin now
we're going to rinse our denture Cup and
notice how dirty it gets you want to
make sure you get all that out of there
because we're going to fill it a little
bit up with water just enough water to
cover the dentures and why do we want to
do that well we want to do that so the
dentures are kept moist because it'll be
easier for the patient to put them back
in and it'll help them keep their shape
now you always want to ask the patient
what they use to soak their dentures in
because some patients use half of a
solution like half vinegar and half
water or a tablet solution so always ask
them that now what we want to do is
we're going to start cleaning the
dentures so we're going to get our
toothbrush and we're going to start
inward and work our way outward and see
rinsing helps remove a little
that but you have to watch out because
down in the gumline you will get a lot
of pace because a lot of patience use
pace on their dentures and food
particles and that's just a nasty
reservoir for germs and bacteria to get
in so making sure you really clean that
area very good and then looking at the
front of the teeth as well getting that
cuz food particles like to get in there
no one wants anything in their teeth
whenever they put their teeth back in so
you want them nice and clean and then
flip them over and get up where the
palate part would be as well okay and
then we're going to rinse those
let's get them nice and rinse we put
them in your denture cup now we're going
to clean our bottoms and again we're
gonna follow the same way we did with
the other ones clean and inside that gum
line really good and make sure all the
bacteria and food particles and
everything's removed and brush on the
back teeth and the front teeth molars
just like how you would brush your
natural teeth getting inside where the
tongue would lay and then return to your
denture cup which has the water in it
and we'll put the lid back on the cup
now what we're going to do is we're
going to rinse our toothbrush and our
basin get that cleaned get the
toothbrush and really rub your finger
your gloved finger over that toothbrush
to get all the food particles out and
the toothpaste out get it nice and clean
and then I like to take a paper towel
and just dry that Basin out that
toothbrush dried as well and just put
that back in there then turn your water
off don't forget to pull the stopper and
let the water drain out and then we'll
take our towels once all the waters
drained out put it in the linen and
we're going to doff our gloves and
perform perform hand hygiene and then
when you're done don't forget to provide
oral care to your patient and assist
them with putting their dentures back in
if they choose to okay so that wraps up
how to clean dentures as a nurse thank
you so much for watching and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more videos